si william h
ruth ellen brosseau a adopté yamachiche
à tous les points de vue elle vise sur
une ferme élèves des sangliers avec son
conjoint un autre contre emploi pour
cette végétarienne
parce que je mange pas de viande non
plus jugé qui se remet toujours de sa
défaite crève coeur ou dernières
élections c'est toute la natation parce
que le jour mais c'est tout un
changement de vie pendant huit ans tous
les fins de semaine j'étais dans des
activités le jour lendemain de la
défaite il ya personne qui t'appelle tu
as pas d'invitation ce soir un deuil à
faire le pour l'instant je suis entre
deux eaux sereine
la conservatrice sylvie boucher ne sait
toujours pas ce qu'il l'attend après 35
ans expliqué en politique quand vous
êtes habitué à rouler 71 à 81 en semaine
et tu tombes à rien tu cherches un peu
je tombe un peu dans le vide
et comme j'ai horreur du vide j'ai
essayé de continuer à m'impliquer dans
ma communauté
oui on peut sortir de la politique m'ont
fait pour sortir la politique les filles
parlez-en à jean françois lisée je
m'ennuie de la politique tous les jours
mais pas toute la journée
plus d'un an après la déconfiture du pq
la défaite a toujours un goût amer c'est
sûr que ça irait mieux si j'avais gagné
c'est sûr donc une défaite c'est une
défaite il faut faire la paix avec la
défaite
et peu importe le résultat on est
toujours très épuisés en tout cas moi je
suis épuisée et on ne s'habitue pas à
perdre après avoir goûté au pouvoir au
provincial
après une défaite en 2014 après un
changement d'allégeance politique
réjean hébert n'a pas réussi son entrée
au fédéral il fallait un peu de temps
pour être capable de
daval et de gérer et retomber sur mes
pieds qu'elle l'ait fait tinter la crève
coeur celle ci cela 2014
seul de 2014 après le repos la réflexion
est nécessaire
la réorientation aussi essaient pour
certains un retour n'est jamais exclu
qui sait après je représenterai encore
pour moi c'est une ses portes se fermer
à jamais pour d'autres la défaite aura
marqué la fin de leur carrière en
politique active
une autre campagne le dojo de m'attacher
et si jacques andré charbonneau radio
canada
mon frère